[Music]
do you realize how special this woman is
she taught me sign language uh through
the mail i had a deaf cellmate made it
so i could talk to someone oh show him
the sign that you made up kai no i don't
know it's
it okay yeah
okay yeah that that's cool uh what does
that mean represents an emotion
that the english language does not have
a word for
when you want something but
you can't have it
oh well uh you know just off top my head
there's uh unobtainable elusive
right you said you bought a present
kai
i can see you worked
really hard and put a lot of thought
into this
but this makes me uncomfortable
you know that though don't you
you normally give me beautiful drawings
like like those tall
ships is this some sort of power move
because you knew that jack was gonna be
here can i see it please just just real
quick
excuse me sir could you do me a big
favor could you throw this into your
filthiest garbage can yeah okay i'll
definitely do that
i'm bouncing
dude would probably have more fun
without me anyway
i knew having the two of you meat would
be a disaster
that's why i told you not to come told
me not to come
you said i was more than welcome
that means don't come
that's what marcus said
[Music]
i'm really sorry he left because of me
he's at the host stand
what
oh
you know what i'll go talk to him go
ahead
you're more than welcome
okay
hey bud yeah i might want to slow down
on those we still have dessert
life hack
free mints are dessert
oh okay well listen you know if you want
something else we did just order a big
brownie
shayshay and i always order the apple
pie
huh
all right well hey if you guys want
apple pie i'm not gonna stand in the way
hey what was she talking about with the
tall ships what my drawings yeah
uh i mean
pictures
can i see them
okay well uh this tall ship there's a
shark coming straight at it you can't
see it cause it's underwater but i mean
i know it's there oh no no i i know it's
there too because of how scared the
sailors look yeah that that's really
good man
wow
i am truly sorry about the drawing
it sucked
[Music]
thanks molokai
[Music]
good job on the hands incredibly
realistic hands are not easy to
draw you know malachi
we should do this again sometime
golly gee do you really mean it
i was kind of asking for real
i was just protecting myself with
sarcasm oh okay uh well yes
for real yeah that'd be cool with me ah
quick choose between us
uh what do you mean when there's one
dice was it gonna be just a game
oh god um
one
um well i mean i i guess i got to go
with shayla to live
oh no no i'm i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
you and i just met tonight
plus
we're dating right stupid
probably wasn't even a fun debate thank
you for humoring me it's fine
it's a very fun game